je me tiens ici en sachant que mon histoire fait
partie de l'histoire américaine plus large que
j'ai une dette envers tous ceux qui sont venus
avant moi et que dans aucun
autre pays sur terre mon histoire n'est même
possible [
Musique]
[Musique]
je  a grandi sans mon père, il est
parti quand j'avais deux ans
et même si ma sœur et moi avons eu
la chance d'avoir une mère merveilleuse
et des grands-parents attentionnés pour nous élever, j'ai
ressenti son absence
et je me demande à quoi aurait ressemblé ma vie
il a été une plus grande présence
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu la politique comme un jeu
depuis le jour où j'ai décidé de devenir
organisateur communautaire dans le sud de
chicago il y a plus de
deux décennies j'ai toujours vu
la politique
comme une mission comme la façon dont nous  tenir
ce pays à la hauteur de nos idéaux les plus élevés
[Musique]
je ne pensais pas que c'était possible mais
laissez-moi vous dire aujourd'hui que
j'aime mon mari encore plus qu'il y a
quatre ans
encore plus qu'il y a 23 ans lorsque
nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la première fois
laissez-moi vous dire pourquoi voyez-vous j'aime
qu'il n'ait jamais oublié comment il a
commencé
ensemble
où vivent encore des espoirs communs et des rêves communs
je me tiens devant vous aujourd'hui pour annoncer
ma candidature à la présidence des
états-unis d'amérique
mon certificat de naissance
[Musique
] [Musique]
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est important de reconnaître que
la communauté afro-américaine se
penche sur cette question à travers
un ensemble d'expériences et une histoire
qui ne disparaît pas
[Musique]
ce fut un honneur et un privilège de
travailler côte à côte
avec vous pour renforcer notre démocratie
et avec cela j'ai juste deux mots de plus
pour vous dire
obama